herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
leuten ich bin jetzt zusammen mit lutz
ich habe mir was überlegt ich wusste
nicht wirklich was hier aufnehmen sollen
dann dachte ich mir nämlich doch mit
challenge und wandeln sie ein bisschen
ab ich hab mich einfach mary chain
inspiriert da muss man entscheiden wen
auf drei personen meinen heiraten ticken
und töten möchte und wir machen das
ganze heute mit abo löschen aufnehmen
also welchen youtuber würde man
abonnieren welchen würde man von youtube
löschen und mit welchen die schüler will
man aufnehmen und ab haben wir hier
schon so ein paar schildchen vorbereitet
bekommen von der ersten dame hinter der
kamera
hallo hinter der kamera nicht retten
würde
du kannst du beginnst du siehst dreimal
danach bin ich dran
ok 12 keine ahnung was für youtuber da
drinstehen da schon ob man ärgert er
sich über ist lina sophie melina wir das
erste youtube jahre alten youtube zu
leiden haben wird und als dritten
youtuber haben wir dna meine damen und
herren also den adel und medina sowie
soll ich anfangen
da dürfte zu sagen willst du von den
leuten abonnieren
[Musik]
damit ausgeweitet natürlicherweise
mangels alternativen wird man immer
jemanden löschen müssen zum beispiel
besser nicht irgendwie böse gemeint oder
sowas
es ist ein ausschlussverfahren also ich
glaube ich würde
mit dem aufnehmen
ich würde mir abonnieren und ich hatte
löschen
weil die täter fuhren bettvorleger
kanada weiter auch auf der anderen
plattformen bringen also ich weiß nicht
ob bei den anderen ist es ja so diebe
nehmen und wirklich bei den einnahmen
werden sodass der sich auf eine andere
plattform suchen können sie überhaupt
kein spontaner das also meine
entscheidung sehr elegant auch noch
etwas ins schwitzen oder wenn irgendeine
andere youtuber auch diese change machen
will dann muss er diesen auf mit
einfügen abonniert
so ist wie ich dreimal 12 wieder
tipptopp entertainment the game übrigens
mit ziemlich staates video bei luca
gemachte marmelade richtig packt euch
alles funktioniert hat so also mein
erster youtuber ist schirin david emrah
und kohlekraft ok wen würde ich von den
leuten die über captain glaubt darin
wenig von den leuten abonnieren
fertig heißt es ich habe doch keine
abonniert dann wäre klug aber mithin mit
ihr aufnehmen
also ich sag schon mal abonnieren würdig
emrah weil ich bin emma macht echt
interessante videos so das kann man
nicht alle zwei monate
ja gut das kann man sich das kann man
sich rein ziehen aber gesagt als bei
monat viel inaktiver macht für ihn david
video und judy davis ich mache jetzt mal
eine erweiterte die welt ist ja auch im
fernsehen unterwegs und evergreens tagen
löschen für ihn da wird kein freund an
der stelle sagen schön damit noch am
ehesten von den dreien und aufnehmen
würde ich mit konkreten ihm alles
genommen was ist dran zieht wieder 3play
und die drei youtube gelöscht habe ich
noch den youtube an und ich habe noch
juli an werden dann ganz easy
unterziehen würde ich abonnieren mit
darf den video aufnehmen kündigt glaube
ich löschen weil ich glaube naja es gibt
natürlich viele leute die den konnte
noch irgendwie feiern von ihm aber es
ist ja auch eine objektive meinung ich
mag die konten nicht so gern deswegen
würde ich sagen ihnen löschen an der
stelle weil die anderen beiden auch
persönlich kennen und deswegen julia
bohn ihren mein guter freund julien
den würde ich mit einem video aufnehmen
und lea machete
leider hat mit ihren mittätern runter
von youtube 123 kg die habe ich hier
einmal dann habe ich grade kraft wird
das wände und farbe okay abonnieren man
kann sich ja wissen gehört nicht
abonnieren will ich auf jeden fall würde
ich mich wenn flächen oder danni wie ich
glaube die kurzzeit überlegen da
gebieten und mit mir selbst aufnehmen
und ein video vom spiegel dreher dann
schreibt in die kommentare
ok meine damen und herren das ist mein
letzter durchlaufen
ich habe jetzt drei youtuber gezogen die
sind elf fragen wir sie mal und dritten
youtuber katja casa sitze
das halt ich würde das wieder hängen
aber eigentlich kann von glück reden
dass ich eigentlich jetzt tatsächlich
zweimal youtube hatte die wehr von
vertraglichen konnten produzieren an der
este will ich auf jeden fall ist hier
keine krankheit der kasache definitiv
löschen würde also ich glaube ich
rechtzeitig 90 prozent über würden mir
sagen ob ich recht geben
sie kann das wirklich was die macht auch
auf komplett anderen plattform hochladen
deswegen werde ich nicht mal schlimmste
liebt geht zum abonnieren und aufnehmen
da ist mit edgar ja schon relativ häufig
aufgenommen habe würdig and can send
them aufnehmen also wenn der notation
leute welche welche drei werde ich will
sie nicht mit dem den und dem herrlich
meine drei letzten kandidaten sind babys
beauty spa leckere auch nicht mal drei
abonnieren durch von lieven
abonnieren sie möchten wir so tolle
gewinnspiele freisprechen begreifen
zugreifen also ich bin echt überlegen
ich glaube löschen wenn ich von den
tatsächlich abo radfahrerin konnte und
akkurat schlimmere ausreichen weil das
ablöschen kabarettist die feuerwehr
abonniert und mit wem nämlich auf den
kritiker behörden guten putzig wird er
noch mit resi aufnehmen damit zb
abonnieren aber ich glaube darin muss
jetzt einfach wieder leben gut
integriert euch gefallen
ich glaube da kommt jetzt nicht mehr so
viel schnee fallen euch gefallen hat
dann das gerne einen like darf hier noch
eine weitere folge wollt dann lasst auch
ein leichter aber den anderen like damit
ich weiß dass ihr meint was bisher nicht
natürlich